[Musique]
dans la tasse ça
met le bien la misère dans la tasse
ça même pas la misère dans la
terrasse alors
[Musique]
danser
alors danser un petit Ségard
du Conservatoire le chef d'orchestre
et là les diamants choisis 10 à 12 sites
et à partir de là les iMac elle
arrangeait me voir elle est vrai que ma
théorie
Diao au-delà de mes espérances parce que
le truc c'est que moi je reste quand
même sur mon tempo tu vois et là c'est
vrai que ça je peux rentrer dedans le
truc faut retrouver le truc
je voudrais voir quelques petits
est-ce que je peux donc s'il vous plaît
à 50 je crois que c'est 50 non 63
uniquement les bois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sauf que je découvre l'univers du
classique nous on va dire du fila
harmonique et voilà fait le choix de
jouer avec très peu de musique
Basse-Terre ne pas avoir de base
rythmique et que les violons que les
saxophone clarinettes
[Musique]
nous samedi nous dit ça va
le secret alors ce qui a été compliqué
on va dire cette préserver le
l'âme des chansons de Basse-Terre parce
que c'est quelque chose qui est sacré
enfin quand moi je suis un créole fier
de l'être c'est compliqué de toucher à
ces monuments de la chanson réunionnaise
et c'est vrai que ça ça a été un vrai
challenge
viens là-bas
en étant à Los Angeles pour assister à
une répétition à la Réunion ça demande
beaucoup de logistique heureusement il y
a une équipe formidable vraiment Didier
Koki Jean-Pierre tanjon j'ai mis le
Darik enfin tout tous ces messieurs qui
sont dans l'ombre et qui œuvrent au bon
fonctionnement du projet
[Musique]
là-bas des 6 chemins
et ça pose la corde là-bas mettez
l'école et Sharon brouillard
et ça redouillard alors j'ai toujours
proposé aux artistes donc
identifiés pour cette carte blanche de
s'appuyer sur un sur un orchestre
symphonique de base et après on a juste
mais ça permet d'avoir un équilibre
entre avoir les cordes les bois les
cuivres les percussions plus le groupe
ça permet d'avoir vraiment une
homogénéité puis surtout une patte de
son intéressante
[Musique]
un morceau comme gawei qui sonne
vraiment reggae
il est on peut retransports
[Musique]
c'est toujours incroyable d'entendre
cette idée qui était dans ma tête et que
j'étais le seul à avoir entendu là de
l'entendre prendre vie au fil des
répétitions c'est vraiment incroyable
comme sensation je sens que ça va être
vraiment un moment exceptionnel entre la
musique de Basse-Terre qui rencontre
l'orchestre symphonique c'est vraiment
quelque chose à ne pas rater je pense et
en tout cas moi j'aurais beaucoup aimé
être là
[Musique]
que nous peut attendre à nous dans le
futur un pasteur avec une musique
classique également pourquoi pas
l'évolution c'est ça qui permet de
subsister de vivre c'est-à-dire sur
évolue pas après faut que le feeling
faut ressemble alors en tout cas comme
il écoute ça bien sûr
[Musique]